Oscar winners Sir Ben Kingsley has acted
in dozens of critically it came
clinically critically acclaimed movies
over his more than fifty year career
Kingsley is known for his unforgettable
roles in movies like Gandhi Schindler's
List and House of Sand and Fog I
remember that now he's starring in the
historical thriller operation finale
it's based on the real-life Israeli
mission to capture Adolf Eichmann one of
Nazis chief architects of the Holocaust
Kingsley portrays Eichmann who has been
hiding in Argentina with his family
under an alias after World War two we
have our guy I don't like who the
architect of the final solution we
should be putting him down like a mad
dog I would happily put a bullet in
between his eyes but that's not what
we're doing here strictly catch an
extract Eichmann will stand trial here
in Israel my job was simple save the
country I loved from being destroyed
whom did we take from you Peter
whom did you man in this picture as you
SS number 45 381 my director
again your number was 45 381 your number
was 45 381 45 381 45 381 was for 5 3 to
6 then our facts have my fate my name is
huddle fireman Sir Ben Kingsley joins us
now at the table good morning to you
that was that was such a very crucial
scene in the movie and the thing that
got to me about this movie Ben is that
he's such a despicable character in
history yet we saw the humanity of this
man and of this man with his family with
his dog with his wife and it was hard
for me to reconcile the two well I I
think that you've hit on one of the many
tensions that run through the phone and
I'm I'm delighted that that's your
dilemma because that's the dilemma that
we want to awaken in the audience I
think if we fictionalized the man as a
monster body wrote unquote then we
relegate that horrendous portion of
history to fiction and it's either
easier to forget digest or dismiss but
when we when we insist on the audience
to accept these these men and women as
men and women then it makes that period
of history much harder to deal with but
we must must confront it and deal with
it Mike when was one of us and it's not
your first film based on the Holocaust
obviously Galen mentioned Schindler's
List you had murders among us before
that where you played Simon Wiesenthal
Alto frankenz father yes and I'm
interested in knowing about the
preparation that went into this role as
a Nazi you played Holocaust survivors
before you played Jews before obviously
what went into this role in preparing
for I can answer very simply because I
know we don't have a lot of time but
meeting Simon Wiesenthal playing Otto
Frank playing his ax turn and meeting so
many survivors on Schindler
and other survivors to case for example
who hid Anne Frank's family in her attic
which is she was a wonderful woman
died did 102 and interlaced with this I
also had the privilege of meeting Elie
Wiesel the the the great prophet and
poet of and witness of the Holocaust and
survivor and when I was last with early
I did have the opportunity to tell him
to his face that the next time I walk
onto a film set this relevant II war
story I will dedicate my performance to
you so really I did not immerse myself
in Nazism or German nationalism I
immersed myself in the memory of every
cell and every day I said to myself and
to a photograph of him I had in my
pocket le I'm doing this for you and
that was my engine that was my fuel Wow
why didn't take it from Nazism I took it
from Le what a tribute and why connect
those two things with what you said
earlier which is that Eichmann is one of
us why is that so important to keeping
the memory of the Holocaust survivors
alive and because I think if we dismiss
them in in a sort of capsule an
aberration of history saying well they
weren't really human said they don't
count then we're really letting history
off the hook and we were in grave danger
of allowing it to happen again and I
know that le last time I heard him speak
he actually said that in his prayers to
God I think he actually had
conversations with God after the
Holocaust he said what more do you want
in the light of anti-semitism in the
light of extreme Islam in the light of
everything that's threatening the Jewish
Diaspora he was saying what other
sacrificed you want to stop this is six
million not enough apparently not which
is tragic what a blessing to his memory
and it's such a moving film thank you so
much for mr. Ben Kingsley we appreciate
it
operation finale is in theaters August
29th